hello ladies and gentlemen on them to be
able to welcome today in paris
it's prime minister first of all to say
how important the relationship of two countries
essential and unalterable words ambitious
we pay ryckewaert is perfectly
that it's
genetic this weekend is  in manila or in
october
the tariff is said we at the quantum level
carry out a diet genomics the hold up that
they act m
the french president is too old
ecology education is joe pesci uk
france which divides
ron which opened the mark
in capital economic policy  city landes le me
d one of the biggest french is said to be on of
and our romanian doctors 1 in a cau
e wing but if the president of th
ja vichy clinton seemed